Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
im game und alles stimmt da bin ich ja zuviel ich ja froh was nackt wieder
jetzt wird gebashed mal aufwärmen moin alexi sama
alexi sama, gebashed, gebashed
geh weg steemo fale, verbiss dich ich hab da was gehört
und den holen wir uns jetzt der wird jetzt geschreckt
ich weiß nicht von wo ich verpiss mich mal was ok
ach da auch sehr fairer spawn das müsste irgendwo hinter dem gegner sein
sag mal das fof ist doch wieder festgestellt oder? kann das sein?
ich hab echt was gehört hat er sich rumgeschleicht
call of duty tot musste sein servus mark spielst du noch bdo ab und zu mal
ich muss sagen das game hat mich einfach nicht so geschockt
so der spawned hinter mir den holen wir uns
was?
oh outplayed outplayed hat er gewartet hat er mich gehört
ähm es gibt gibt es nen perk ich glaub ich hab so was gelesen
dass ein die gegner nicht mehr hören oder schlechter hören
und man vor allem selber man vor allem selber wieder mehr hört
hier müssen wir rauf achtung
ich hör was oh voll hinten nein
aber komm erste runde gewinnen wir klein was ist das?
schock war das ne auto shotgun der hat zu schnell geschossen
hinter mir ist einer gespawnt ich muss mal hier weg
das fof stimmt nicht aber das mit dem aim läuft schon wieder
viel besser als der erste tag
schnell kommt noch einer jetzt ich hab hinter mir was gehört
fuck ich wollt nen sicheren platz für meinen pilot
so viele gegner alle gegner da alle gegner da
echt hart umkämpft das free for all warte warte aber hardcore warte bällchen
oh man so viele leute überall
ich lese das gleich im chat ich kann gar nicht
wie findest du die rx 580 ist das ne amd graphic karte oder ne amd graphic karte an
die runde müssen wir klein mal gewinnen was richtig wir ist dass man dann halt echt
schritte von allen seiten ich glaub ich musste den alten free for all trick machen einfach
am rand der map rumkriechen was denn das
eventuell
Okay, 3 Kills Vorsprung
Cover
Der hat ein Schleich Park drin habe ich nicht gehört
Den habe ich nicht gehört warum habe ich den nicht gehört
Warum habe ich den nicht gehört?
Ich habe den null gehört
War das Division Perk oder sowas?
Wir sind wieder 2 Kills hinten
Und warum?
Viele Bomben
Komm jetzt ein Kill noch, ein Kill noch
Fuck
Knapp
Knapper Scheiß
So Eaxe bist du da?
Mp40 geht gut ab
Kann man echt empfehlen
Können wir erst noch ein paar Runden TDM spielen?
Mein Game hängt wieder
Fick dich dieser Kack PC Port
Meine Fresse
Ich komme wieder aus dem Game nicht raus
Ich kann wieder nichts aufmachen
Fick dich Activation
Dieser Kack PC Port mich regt so auf
Einfach nur weil ich rausgetappt bin
Das kann doch am besten Willen nicht sein
Dass ich aus dem Spiel nicht raus tappen darf
Ich kann das Game nicht beenden
Es geht nicht
Ich darf es nicht ausmachen
Und nachdem ich nicht in Task Manager komme
Ich muss mir ein Programm machen
Ich muss mir ein Skript machen
Was
Kot abschießt wenn ich es ausführe
Das ist anscheinend notwendig der Kack
Was mache ich denn jetzt
Wie komme ich jetzt hier aus dem Kack Game Run
Naja doch ich kann den Task Manager ja aufmachen
Aber Task Manager ist im Hintergrund
Weil das Game mit einem verfickten vollbildschwarzen Bildschirm da ist
Wie es mich aufregt
Kann es nicht einfach laufen
Das kriegt die 2 Mann Glitche
Aus der Frankfurter Gosse hin besser programmiert
Und es ist ja nicht so das das erste Problem war
Was wir mit dem Game hatten
Permanent läuft das Scheiß nicht
Ich habe kein Bock jetzt wieder Stream auszumachen
Nur weil das Game abgekackt ist
Ich muss jetzt Stream ausmachen
Ausloggen wieder einloggen
Weil ich ja nichts sehen darf
Weil Vollbild ist ganz böse
Und Vollbild muss man komplett den Bildschirm schwarz zeichnen
Dass ich nicht meinen Task Manager öffnen kann
Super
Wenn es ja nicht mal der Task Manager in Vollbild
Ich frage jetzt Google
Kill Call of Duty Background
Gibt es natürlich nicht
Wir können
Oh wir machen jetzt Trick 17
Wir
Wir tappen uns jetzt durch den Task Manager durch
Nur mit der Alt-Tab Übersicht
End-Task
Ja
Ich habe es geschafft
Game ist aus
Das ist aber voll durch die Brust ins Auge
So ich habe es ausgeschaltet
Ich habe es geschafft
Haha
Ja das wird funktionieren
Aber ich habe den 2. Monitor an meinem 2. Rechner
Ich habe keinen 2. Monitor
Aber ich weiß jetzt wie ich es mache
Übels Trick 17
Ich sehe ja nichts mehr
Also auch den Task Manager nicht
Das heißt ich mache jetzt Task Manager auf
Dazu drückt man halt einmal
Fallen nach unten
Und Menü-Taste und End-Task
Also irgendwie
Unten
Dings-Taste
Rechts-Click-Taste
Unten Enter und dann geht Code aus
Aber jetzt weiß ich immerhin wie es funktioniert
Es ist schlimm dass es
Ich meine
Ich tapp halt aus dem Game raus
Das ist ja jetzt nichts
Was nicht vorgesehen ist
Oder so
Das muss jedes Programm abkönnen
So was für eine Aufregung
Spielst du nicht mit randlosem Fenster
Ne ich habe es jetzt auf Vollbild umgestellt
Weil die Performance in Vollbild besser ist
Aber trotzdem ganz ehrlich
Rein, raus, tapp
Das kann es doch nicht sein
Ejax können wir erstmal ein paar
Team Deathmatch spielen ohne Discord
Dass ich noch ein bisschen Chat lesen kann
Bisherige Meinung zu dem Spiel
Fragt Bozinga
Bist du schon länger als eine Minute
Im Stream?
Nur gefragt so
Weil dann hättest du es eben mitgekriegt was ich von dem Game halte
Ich bin gerade übels ausgeflippt
Weil ich mir zum 500.000 abgekackt ist
So Social
Mal gucken ob das heute geht
Friends, Ejax du bist angeblich nicht online
Doch jetzt
Ehm
Evoli fragt
Ich kenne mich da nicht aus
Sag mal ob die Kacke erzählen
Habe einen Monat gewartet
Bis der Techniker kommt um das Internet zu aktivieren
Am Tag kam keiner
Absolut niemand
Hab draußen gewartet
Ein Anbieter sagt mir dass er nicht kam
Weil der APL irgendwelche falsch läuft
Wieso wissen die das jetzt erst
Und woher wissen die das
Morgen kommt es angeblich wieder einer passiert ist irgendwie nichts
Die labern scheiße
Die haben das nicht im Griff
Es ist so oft dass
Wie gesagt wird dass irgendwelche Techniker vorbeikommen
Von der Telekom da kommt keiner und sowas
Einfach sinnlos gelaber
Die kriegen es nicht gebacken
Aber
Macht ihr nichts draus
Die anderen Anbieter sind fast noch alle schlimmer als die Telekom
Wie viel ist dein PC wert
Ehm
Du meinst jetzt alles zusammen was da drin ist
Geh mal auf mein YouTube Channel letztes Video
Und guck dir den Geizhalz Link an
Irgendwie 2000
Muss ich jetzt erst mal nachgucken
Wie viele Rechner insgesamt mit Grafikkarten
In allem wieviel das an Kohle kosten würde
Ehm
Geizhalz Link sagt der Rechner würde kosten
2351 Euro
Ist das PC Command aktuell
Krass
Border Sebaro
Geil
So ich such mal ein Match
Ist doch realistisch
1942 war die Technik noch nicht so ausgereift
Das wird sein
Ja da PC
Ja aber also ich hab auch nicht alles von dem PC bezahlt
Also Grafikkarte hab ich von Nvidia gekriegt
Vor einem halben Jahr ungefähr
Und das heißt da geht nochmal ganzen Batzen weg
Aber teuer war das Ding trotzdem
Aber ich war immerhin ganz sicher sonst nichts
Früher war es einfach so
Man hatte Zeit
Und hatte kein Geld
Und heute hat man Geld und hat keine Zeit
Das ist total bescheuert
Warum kann ich die Kombination sein
Das ist auch eine der Gründe warum ich nur 4 Tage die Woche noch arbeiten gehe
Kann ich mal irgendwann im Leben so die Kombination eintreffen
Man hat Zeit und man hat Kohle
Und man kann auch was machen
Also weil wenn man irgendwann Rentner ist und vielleicht Zeit hat und Geld
Dann kann man nichts machen
Welche Waffe?
MP40 habe ich letztens gespielt
Stimmend habe ich gelesen
Die haben jetzt ein Smartphone
Ich hatte ja was geplant mit Alienware
Aber das
Haben wir uns dann drauf geeinigt
Dann haben wir irgendwann zu einem späteren
Zeitpunkt mal
Ich wollte erstmal wieder ein bisschen regelmäßig was machen
Bevor man da irgendwas in der Richtung
Zusammen macht
Ist der Unterschied zwischen M2 und
SSD also du meinst wahrscheinlich
SATA SSD
Groß in der Wand lohnt sich eine M2 nie
Lohnen tut sich das gar nicht
Das ist einfach nur
Ist die Lautstärke okay?
Ingame Sound, mein Gelaber und sowas?
Moment, wo geht es hier lang auf der Map?
Ach da kommt jetzt gleich einer
Wir gehen jetzt mal in die Mitte rein
We are dominating
Moment
Oh ich muss Schalldämpfer drauf machen
Wobei, das Team Last Match braucht keinen Schalldämpfer
Oh, geschneibt
Ich hasse Sniper
Wisst ihr was es geben müsste?
Man müsste Custom Server machen können
Wobei, kann man Custom Server machen?
Kann man nicht oder?
Und dann müsste man Sniper Limit machen
Wie in Battlefield
Oh Mann
Scheiße, ich hab aufgehört zu schießen
Ich bin jetzt tot
Wo geht hier was?
Die kommen jetzt von der anderen Seite, oder?
Ja, ja, ja, ja
Geh raus
Oh
Von der anderen Seite war klar
In dem Game geht es mir total oft so
Dass ich quasi schon
Schüssel ins Gesicht kriege
Bevor ich überhaupt eine Chance habe
Zu Orten wo Gegner sind
Oh, ich hör was
Wo?
Der Hellstrike könnte ein Stück schneller sein
Was?
Call of Duty Tod
Ihr war schön von der Seite in your face
Wir flenken da jetzt rum
Ich brauche Rapid Fire Leute
Ich brauche Rapid Fire
Mit Rapid Fire wird so gerapt
Fuck, ich dachte er kommt halt so lang
Die kommen jetzt von links
Glaub ich zumindest, die Spawns sind mir absolut ein Rätsel
Hauptstraße rennen wir nicht
Hauptstraße kannst du dich quasi gleich selbst in die Luft sprengen
Ich höre hier 50 Milliarden Gegner, aber ich kenne die Laufwege noch nicht
Ich habe krasse Flankaction gemacht, aber nichts gewesen
Der kommt von hinten
Ich habe Input Lack
Ich habe übeles Input
Ich würde jetzt gerne mal einen Gegner finden
Links
Ich lese gleich Chat, ich muss mich konzentrieren
Komm her
Echt?
Fuck, Munition leer
Mit dem Ding kann man nicht so geil aus der Hüfte sprayen
Die müssten von der anderen Seite kommen
Achtung
Richtig dämlich, nicht die richtige Taste getroffen
Kann das sein, dass die alle mittlerweile schon mit Mountain Division rumrennen und man hört nichts?
Die überall laufen von der Seite, ich hasse diese Call of Duty Tode
Ich finde das mit den Schalldämpfern eine coole Taktik ist
Ich dachte wir können jetzt von oben draufspringen
Die Runde müssen wir jetzt gewinnen
Ich habe keine Ahnung wo was ist
Ich mache mal unten dicht
Call of Duty Tode
Komm, das müssen wir gewinnen
Komm, fünf Kills
Verlor, Scheiße
Kann durchaus sein, ich spiele auch alle Divisions auf Prestige
Mountain Division muss mir noch ein Kit machen, habe ich noch nicht
Kaufempfehlung oder nicht?
Das ist schwer zu sagen
Aufgrund der Technik oder wie beschissen es läuft
Vor allem wenn man aus dem Spiel raus tappen muss, was nicht verboten ist
Technisch ist es eine Krücke auf dem PC
Jetzt geht es ab
Steady Aim kommt weg und Rapid Fire kommt dran
Jetzt machen wir uns noch eine Expeditionary
Müssen wir auch mal leveln
MP40 ist echt gut
Spielst du nicht im randlosen Modus?
Nein, ich spiele als Vollbild, weil Vollbild besser läuft
Wäre ein Informatikstudium an der Uni zu schwer gewesen für dich?
Das kann man erst wissen, wenn man es probiert hat
Habe ich nicht probiert, keine Ahnung
Denkst du das wird in zwei Monaten noch aktiv gespielt?
Ich weiß nicht, wir können ja gleich mal
Wir gucken nach der Runde mal Steam Stats
Das kann ja einer von euch in der Zwischenzeit mal Steam Stats gucken
Wie viel das gestern gespielt haben oder heute
Die Map habe ich glaube ich erst einmal gespielt
Gucken wie das Waffenhandling mit Rapid Fire ist
WTF warum spawnen die hinter mir?
Gott warum?
Der Lämpfer ist auf dir
Rapid Fire springt aber auch richtig hin und her
Der Stand war 56.000 heute
Das geht doch
Du checkst null wo Gegner her kommen
Komplett null
Das ist einfach nur randomness pur
Ihr denkt ich laufe hier lang
Das mache ich aber nicht
Der Hells Rock scheint mir auch ein bisschen langsam zu sein
Vielleicht muss mir einfach mehr im Team laufen
Wobei das ist Kot das kann nicht sein
Kot läuft man nicht im Team
Voll auf die Fresse
Der AX geht ab
Das würde mich interessieren wie viele Leute auf der Xbox und Playstation Online sind
Wie soll man das denn spielen?
Die Leute fangen schon wieder an zu sitzen
Das ist meistens der Zeitpunkt wo man immer spielen kann
Die Waffe ist auch übertrieben gut
Zwei Hit
Ich bleibe jetzt einfach hier stehen
Ich mache es jetzt genauso
Kommen die Gegner von der anderen Seite oder?
Ich verstehe den Spawn nicht
Rechte Seite okay
Jetzt müssen wir uns mal hier verschatzen
Weil wenn ich hier rausgehe kriege ich Artillerie auf dem Kopf
Der Typ hat die haben alle die man nicht hört
Die haben alle dieses Mountain Ding
Da wo man keine Schritte mehr hat
Das ist so kacke
Der Modus ist eh schon links und rechts random gespawn
Und wenn man dann noch nicht mal die Gegner hört
Das ist unmöglich hier kontrolliert zu spielen
Ich höre was von hinten
Ich kann hier die Ecke verstecken
Ich kann mich hier rauf
Komm wir gewinnen jetzt
Haben wir gewonnen? Jawoll
Nice Game hier, der Ejax hat gekariert
Das Spawn System ist einfach zu lernen
Du hast immer das Gefühl sie spawnen hinter dir
Dann spawnen sie nicht hinter dir
Und dann denkst du sie spawnen nicht hinter dir
Dann spawnen sie hinter dir
Doch klar sollte das Spawn System schnell lernbar sein
Es muss logisch sein wo Gegner spawnen
Allerdings sollten die Gegner trotzdem genug Möglichkeiten haben
Dem Spawn Camp zu entgehen
Das geht hier einfach nur darum dass du die Richtung weißt
Dass du genau weißt woher der Gegner kommt
Das geht darum dass du die Richtung weißt
Also quasi dass der Gegner irgendwo ansatzweise aus der Richtung kommt wo du hinguckst
Das sei denn der Gegner umläuft dich halt einmal
Das ist ja ok aber macht der ja meistens gar nicht
Einfach alle 5 Sekunden umdrehen
Wie viele Frames bekommt man denn so?
Also jetzt nachdem ich alles auf Low gestellt habe
So viel wie man halt hier sieht irgendwie 150 oder sowas
Alle mit der 1080 ziel
Ah Kinder
Warum kann man eigentlich nicht chatten in der Lobby?
Kann man ein bisschen trash talk
Oh nein nein bitte nicht die Map
Bitte nicht die Map
Das ist die schlimmste
Das ist die schlimmste Map
FPS werden nicht angezeigt
Ach das ist halt einfach mal random was hier angezeigt wird
Gestern wurden sie noch angezeigt
Also ich habe gerade 150, 127, 124 hier gerade
Beste sniper map die Map ist so hässlich
Ich muss immer noch den Battlefield ticken
Ich drücke Q zum spotten
Mit dem Ding muss man wirklich so schießen
Wenn man zu schnell schießt wird das nichts mit treffen
Ok
Nein nein nein
Ich habe mich übrigens verklickt
Ich will um
Hitmarker
Sniper
Die Map
Ja auf Low gibt es nur 150 FPS
Muss reichen
Ich weiß halt nicht wo sie jetzt herkommen
Das ist echt für mich nicht so ganz durchschaubar
Ach nein das Stream zieht nicht viel Leistung
Warum genau baut man eigentlich so eine Map
Das ist das ist GPU Encoding
Das war drauf
Sniper Max
Ich hasse sie echt ich will den Kram nicht spielen
Was denn das
WTF
Das braucht drei Stunden zum Nachladen
Das ist total ell Seen
Das war nix. Das war zu schnell gequickscoped.
Haha, den hat's aber zerrissen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung wo die Gegner herkommen.
So, fertig gesnived.
Keiner da.
Und wo?
Auf beiden Seiten wird das schön.
Ist das der schwere Gustav? Die Map heißt doch irgendwie so.
Snipen war nicht erfolgreich.
Oh, da geht er ab.
Ich hab keine Ahnung wo die Gegner herkommen.
Das Essen hier ist Hunger.